and like the girls i know they spend
money like it's water
but is that not because of society as
well that they're
like so women feel like they can't wear
an outfit more than once yes because
they'll post a picture on instagram
whatever and so that's all society-led
and therefore they're constantly buying
new things it's other women it's not for
the men it's other women that shame
do you guys care if your girl wears the
same outfit every day
longer
it's good to go on it
like it's it's women and women i think
it's because they make poor choices and
they don't have any self-control
like i'm like i don't know
accountability yeah
it's definitely some women um the women
that i i am around um they they they're
not like that they're very much um good
with money it's more
it's more for me it's the men that i am
around because we make a certain amount
of money
and some men are
crazy crazy stupid with the money um
i'll give you an example
um i remember
uh the first
uh when i moved away is when i was
playing i was playing in i was playing
in jupiter premier league and then
the first um the first month we got paid
because they will get paid monthly
whereas in the uk you get paid weekly
the first month we got paid a few a few
days after one of um one of my teammates
came up to me and says
um
i need more money and i'm just like what
do you mean you need more money what did
you do with your money he said i just
blew i just blew 6k i'm like
like how what did you do he said women
he went out he so anyways that's that's
his poor decisions um mostly the way the
way i grew up is is it's the women that
that
that are more financially illiterate
yeah
they they the one that that handle the
money they're the one that that that
distribute the money especially coming
from um i'm originally congolese so
um
the way in our cultural well it's
changing now
but the way the way it used to be the
man will go to work the woman will go to
the market the man will come back home
um he'll put the money on the table
um okay this is the money that i've made
and then the woman would then distribute
like this money is for the rent this
money is for food this money is that in
the oven right well i'm happy that
you're around exceptions but it's not
the rule
women still own the majority of consumer
debt you you've also got to take into
account that you're you're around
footballers yeah who
have a tendency and a reputation not to
spend money well
in terms of how they end up after their
career yeah yeah so so like i can
understand you your point of view where
you find that the men around you are
spending money money frivolously while
women are saving it as well that men are
more likely to pursue high risk high
reward as well so if my household my dad
was the entrepreneur whilst my mom
worked so naturally he's gonna spend a
lot more money than my mom would but at
the same time when it's successful
we're good to go and the other thing is
with with the man when he spent that
money society doesn't say it's society
making you spend that money
well i mean they just say it's your poor
decisions like this
no no guy is going to talk to his guy
friend and say oh it's society making
you spend the money okay no you just
made the poor choice you're right it's
point it's poor
poor choices i hunted agree with you but
when you're going to say no no but what
do you guys think about you never been
to the club when guys are popping balls
it's not girls balls
it's really not it's like i've been out
in front of 10k in one night i'm looking
around like
what's your point though so you're
saying that you're saying um you're
saying that men don't make messages they
don't impulse violence
when you go to the club they do
right
i'm saying by and large men make better
financial decisions than women and we
can see this because men make more money
and they and they spend less women make
less money and they spend more so by and
large women make
worse financial decisions i think it's
because women generally are trying to
compensate for something i don't know
what
but i think that's what it comes from i
think it's because women lack
self-control do you think
yeah i think i think we're trying to
satisfy something
we're trying to buy the latest outfit
buy the latest botox you know how many
girls i know that give botox at like 24
25 26.
and they can't afford it it's not like
they're making enough money it's all for
attention i feel like about about every
like just younger people in general how
do you afford all this stuff they can't
i could not and i cannot i don't
understand how do they do it all
they can they don't that's the point
they can't
the people that have that fast lifestyle
like i grew up in a one percent family i
know i know what money looks like and
i'm telling you the richest people i
know don't spend money like that i know
someone that's worth probably 50 to 75
million roughly and they've driven the
same car for 20 years
like it's just a mentality it's
definitely if you haven't had it you're
always going to want if you haven't had
it you're going to want to try and get
it and then and somehow unfortunately if
you haven't come you've come from a
place where you don't have it those
stuff those things make you feel good
unfortunately and it's very sad that we
live in the western society where having
things having stuff makes you feel good
about yourself and having character and
being a person not necessarily that just
comes with self-reflection and and again
understanding yourself so a lot of
people in the west arguably aren't
self-aware we just do things we don't
think about why we do them hence why
we're having this conversation a lot of
girls with and then just do things and
not think about the consequences so you
spend without thinking about the
consequences you do only first i think
the consequences all these things are a
lack of cognitive cognition and making
good decisions for yourself yeah it's
just women are always bailed out for bad
decision we always have an excuse for
women and we never do for men
and we can even in this conversation
nobody when he was talking about his
friend that spent the money nobody in
the room said oh well it's society
making him spend it but everyone we
talked about it the other way around oh
it's society making her spend it i think
men like his friend that that spent a
lot of money has definitely got a
complex like say the guys that pop
bottles in the club they have a complex
that they're trying to fulfill by
popping the bottles and getting the
baddest beers on the table it's a
complex but we just i think where women
have been
i've been hunting to a corner to admit
it men have to haven't got to admit yet
but most men believe the family real
view i wanted that bad as it be so i
bought a bottle of champagne i wanted
this thing to do i'm the guy in the club
but we're not ready to manifest
conversations yet i think we've already
said the man popping balls don't even
get the girl anyway so
what are you saying what yeah it's for
sure isn't it it's just yeah but then
they'll come to your table if you don't
actually have such a business but you'll
get the girl to your table at least
whether if you're put up
so you've seen the tic tacs where the
girl grabs her drink and leaves yeah
like you've seen this
it's well known so like the popping
bottle things okay like certain men to
display ego on the display power and
presence do these things
but again like if they can afford to do
it it is what it is but then if you
can't afford to do that's another
question but based on the information
provided most men are more likely to be
able to afford to be that frivolous
if they're doing it if they're doing it
um